you don't need a financial center that
has five times G its GDP of money of
pieces of paper slushing around doing
nothing productive uh France which is
not in a great state of health either uh
has a much much much smaller financial
sector and average prodct productivity
is higher than 25% higher than than and
income for person is higher than Britain
so you you don't need it the the
financing of the green U deal will
require uh taxing wealth ending tax
Havens and so on but it that would
really not be at all enough even if you
introduce a wealth tax like the one that
Elizabeth Warren and Alexandria oia
Cortez are proposing in the United
States all you'll be able to raise is
about 1% of GDP it's good it's good but
it's not enough we need 5 6 7% to have
the green transition and the creation of
the good quality jobs that we need in
this country in Europe and so
on the main way
of energizing this excess liquidity is
what I referred to
before public investment banks that
issue bonds that operate like sponges
that soak up the liquidity from the real
estate market from uh the uh share
buyback process which is boosting share
prices without any investment without
any quality good quality jobs uh and the
central banks just
announcing to the markets so they will
support the bonds issued by the public
investment banks that was the New Deal
idea originally Frank rusel it's how he
managed to prevent
the perpetuation of the Great Depression
in the United States that basic Public
Finance idea but beyond that we need to
reconsider the model of capital that we
have because think about it every time
you you use an app to buy a train ticket
in this country right you know that
75p goes to train
line uh train line belongs to KKR you've
never heard of KKR KKR owns Boots the
chemists did you know that did you know
that behind the the majority of the
corporations and big Banks like JP
Morgan in the United States Bank of
America
uh US Bank Walmart and so on there are
three companies that you probably have
never heard of Black Rock
Vanguard uh State Street have you heard
of them they own 70% of capitalism right
and your little 75p every time you buy
uh a train line ticket yeah sort of
slashes around through there so you have
a situation where the railway Railway
system in in Britain is siphoning
anything between 170 and 200
million through the apps that you use to
buy a train ticket and that finds itself
into the KKR tax havens of the Cayman
Islands and so on and so forth now that
effectively is a think of it as a system
of extracting value from the real
economy and Si siphoning it off to
create this you know the the super super
super h of
0.1% as long as we keep doing this they
will be no green new deal because those
people will always own the media will
always own Facebook or be able to you
know to buy as many as many you know
sponsored ads on Facebook to poison
politics and to poison democracy unless
we combine public Financial tools that
go back to have their roots in the the
New Deal of ruselt with a challenge to
the property rights over apps over
Faceook Facebook over Railway systems uh
we are not going to be able to save the
planet and create jobs that stop people
from feeling so angry that they vote for
Johnson and
farage
another another thing to add to the
train line story is that train line is
owned by a nested series of 26 companies
a train line is owned by another company
called train line HG which is owned by
another company called HG Holdings so on
and so on there are 26 of these in a row
and why do why do companies do that do
you think it's so that they can never be
identified the where the wealth is can
never be pinned down so they can never
be taxed that's right is the solution to
that global national is that for a
government to tackle is it for
governments to tackle is it going back
to organizations like there I say it the
G20 which are unwieldy unlikely to make
a big decision it's all of that we have
to act local Regional you know
neighborhoods everything but it's but
you know it's a good start is to
renationalize the railways yeah uh and
have an app that belongs to the National
Railway
company yeah it's a good
start can I
say another very good start would be to
acknowledge the idea of the commment
that there are things that we share
there are things that should not be
privatized we used to accept that until
Thatcher really who came along with
there's no such thing as
Society following in Anne rand's
footsteps of altruism is evil if you
remember these two great statements of
the 20th century but those two those two
ideas were really the the basis upon
which we dissolve the notion of the
commons the commons is not only to do
with pieces of land we we know of that
kind of Commons where your sheep can
graze but it's to do with intellectual
property it's to do with a Commons of
knowledge it's to do with shared
resources um shared resources being not
only physical things so we have to start
thinking of of the flow of energy and
and wealth in a in a country in a nation
as something that we have common
interest in it can't be just hi off and
nested in 26 a series of 26 companies
and end up in Arkansas or wherever where
KKR somewhere like that aren't they oh
yeah uh but what is interesting about
KKR is they control 200 companies and
have 4 and a half thousand companies
registered in the Cayman Islands through
which they control those 200 companies
uhuh and did you know that there's
there's an address in Harley Street
number 29 Harley Street which has 15,000
company heads headquarters at it and if
you call them somebody will answer the
phone and she'll say yeah uh sorry D I
can't connect you with
them that it's it's a completely fake
address but it's a because England is
now the the money laundering capital of
the world it really is actually we we
are the real criminals in this um that's
what happens you get 15,000 don't you
this is not Collective guilt
because of the British people are the
victims of the city of London yeah
there's so much to unpick there and I
know I'm not going to be able to unpick
at all um I'm going to pick one small
part though do either of you accept
though that profit and making money is a
force for
creativity it's not the primary force I
don't think I don't know anybody who is
excited about what they make because
it's going to make them money I know
people who are excited about what they
make and who would like to make money
from it and are happy when they do but I
don't I've never met anybody in my
business anyway for whom that's the
primary
motive happiness stems from creativity
from doing something creative something
worthy and if you get some money for
that as well then you're the happiest
person on Earth M the trouble is that
the connection
between getting out of poverty and hard
work has been broken and the connection
between doing something creative and
making lots of money has been broken
this is the problem with capitalism but
I let me to just give give you a little
hint of how that be has become a
systemic failure you know KL marks was
talking about the class struggle in
Manchester how you know the capitalist
is investing in a machine um uh the the
worker has no alternative but work there
and the value of the labor power is
lower than the value of the product you
know but now we we've really moved to a
science fiction version of this think
about it imagine you the CEO of a large
company let's not mention
one you are
beholden to the expectations of these
KKR and black rocks because they own the
companies that own the companies that
that own your shares okay so whether
you're going to get a bonus or whether
you're going to be reappointed depends
on those people okay Pension funds yeah
Equity firms private Equity capital and
so on uh the workers
contribute as part of their you know
payers they earn to a pension fund the
pension fund then is owned or owns the
company that
effectively drives the
co the
CEO any coo if if a CEO today wants to
make a little bit more money do you know
what he has to do it's usually he you
know what he has to do just announce
that he's firing 30% of the workforce it
doesn't really matter whether it this
will reduce profits increase profits
whether it makes Financial sense huh
whether it's from an accounting
perspective the right thing to do any
CEO who announces a c of the workforce
will immediately get money why because
the stock exchange immediately reacts to
news of U
you know redundancies by boosting the
price of the shares a boosting the price
of the shares always transmits into a
boost of the bonuses of the co so the
think about this this is this is this is
a an evil plan really I mean it's a very
clever plan but nobody planned it it's
something that evolves spontaneously
within Monopoly capitalism the worker
pays part of his wage into a pension
fund which then demands of the COO that
the worker is fired so that the share
goes
up beautiful isn't
it it's a circle um I want to just a
couple of things before we open it up to
everybody here who've been busy washing
glasses you you haven't noticed they
were there uh one is this idea of the
worker of capital linking back through
we talked about climate change I wonder
whether you think a lot of this could be
made redundant first by the changes that
climate change may bring and secondly by
AI people are talking about thousands of
T hundreds of thousands of people losing
their jobs white color jobs blue color
jobs because of AI the driverless car
the law firm that can you know look at
contracts simply by putting them through
a
computer the sort of the the the joining
of those two events how dangerous is
that are we even thinking about how they
might
interact some people are there's very
interesting new book by Stuart Russell
just came out which is about the more
dystopian possibilities of of a AI um I
can't remember the the name at the
moment I'm afraid um but the the
interesting thing about AI is that
really we should call it machine
learning AI is a thing we haven't
actually got to much of that yet it's
machine learning and machine learning is
looking at lots and lots of data and
finding patterns that aren't intuitive
that aren't obvious without a machine
learning system and then trying to
create responses based on that and it it
would be very interesting if we said to
a machine Learning System what should we
do about climate change um if we trusted
it enough to actually take its result
seriously because I I think it would be
revolutionary if we if we did accept
that we were now in a position where our
own intuition was not sufficiently
evolved to deal with this very complex
and big problem and that we needed that
kind of help I'd like to see the results
of that
um what what I think is happening now is
that we're moving into a sort of
non-intuitive phase of our history the
complexity that we're dealing with is so
so rich and uh as as any of you who know
about Chaos Theory will understand the
number of outcomes the number of
possible outcomes is so large that we
need help in dealing with this we can
get that help by crowd
sourcing by trusting each other's
opinions and amassing them and looking
at how well the data is being digested
but we could also do it I think somewhat
with machine learning I'm alone among my
friends in this cuz most of them deeply
distrust it but I'm alone among my
friends in also thinking that we should
be now looking at nuclear power as a
serious um we we were talking earlier to
about you were mentioning lignite the
Germans using lignite why are the
Germans using lignite the dirtiest fuel
on the planet because the unfortunately
the German greens persuaded them to shut
down their nuclear power stations it
wasn't a great German Angela Merkel
deciding like that after Fukushima that
she would get more votes if she shut
them down yeah maybe the greens had no
influence
yeah Angela they were they were happy to
support her um opportunism yeah but they
were happy to support it I look you
remember we were having a chat uh
backstage beforehand and uh we said that
we were asked do you disagree on
anything and we couldn't find anything
disagree here we found something to
disagree on I'm against nuclear power
and you know why not just because of you
know the fact that we don't know what to
do with nuclear waste but primarily cost
it really now I mean you're right 10
years ago when merel made that choice it
was a mistake from a climate change
perspective but now to start designing
and building new nuclear power stations
irrelevant the cost and efficiency of
wind and solar um has become so
wonderful I mean
let are you aware of the the land area
involved to try to replace Coal Power
it's it's not a question I thoroughly
agree now now we capacity the capacity
to have floating solar panels and wind
turbines that will produce a 100% of
energy within the next 5 Years Around
the World this is this is now clearly
visible with existing technology not
with we have to we have to look at the
arithmetic of this yeah we we've looked
at the arithmetic I mean people have
looked at the arithmetic okay look we
are disagreeing on something um but let
let let me go to the to the key question
about um
Ai and the singularity moment that
people talk about that there will come a
moment very soon maybe six months two
years when the number of jobs created by
the new technology is going to be far
far less than the number of jobs that
will be destroyed because yeah every
technological innovation destroyed jobs
but up until now it has been creating
more jobs than it has been destroying
and now the singularity moment is when
AI will destroy you know 45% of
professions all in one year or
two